lost all his points I'd rather be with
the NFL football playing a [__]
Pokemon these days though hey you got
the money it don't matter
anybody here a fan of Pokemon cards I
don't know [__] about them I you know I
actually looked up my value of like some
of my cards yeah I hate them because I
think all my cards are [__] useless
why you don't got like a [__] good
story no Charizards you know what's
funny I remember when I was a kid when I
was in karate class I was probably like
five or no it's probably like six or
seven Shotokan yeah I should have
conquer ready the real karate yeah real
[__] my boy uh I think I traded my
[__] Charizard for like a much much
uh the guy with the four arms why I
don't know dude because I thought he was
cool my chance because he had cool
muscles yeah
I don't want this Dragon Ball yeah dude
uh yeah one of the muscle guy I want a
muscly one versus a hologram Dragon I
think that ruined my my net worth I
think I think there was a mistake that I
made when I was a kid because he's like
this sparkly dragon is kind of feminine
I want the muscly one I was like the
dragon doesn't have a six-pack bro like
I mean it's kind of true
um well so I got beef with it you were
wrong
um there was an NFL player who uh who
quit playing recently and is now trading
Pokemon cards and says uh he earns just
about the same what just by trading
Pokemon cards last November Blake
Martinez quit the NFL to pursue his
career in trading and selling Pokemon
cards 29 year old Las Vegas Raiders
linebacker announced his retirement on
IG to focus on family and future passion
good for him while he didn't reveal at
that time the exact reason why he was
quitting uh because everyone's gonna
make fun of him like d fans noticed that
uh the NFL star dropped off one of the
rarest cards in the world to a trading
page
um he made let me see
backstory backstory backstory blah blah
blah blah blah he used to trade Pokemon
cards a lot when he was young and he
like [__] loved it and then when he
had to do
um football like he like fell off of it
but once covid-19 the pandemic happened
he like that's also when Pokemon cards
started going crazy again so he just got
back into it
um he said
I lost track of collecting once I
started playing football but years later
uh covid-19 happened everything started
to Skyrocket with trading cards I called
my mom to see what I had left she told
me the cards had either been thrown away
or given away [__] [__] when I
decided to get back into the Hobby and
start recollecting keep my [__] two
years ago yeah two years ago Martinez
quickly realized that he could make
enough money from Pokemon cards to have
it as a potential full-time job wow
full-time job he realizes from twitch
streamers and other streaming platforms
doing these box breaks so box breaks
include 36 packs of Pokemon cards all of
which contain 11 cards each Pokemon
FedEx bid on these cards with the hope
of attaining to obtaining some rare uh
fines though there is obviously no
guarantee is it old gen cards though
yeah yeah so so like gen sealed pass
yeah you would get like a box of like 36
packs of like uh like generation
whatever I think wow I think that the
old cards were reprinted in what is
considered a later generation but it's
the same thing so it just depends on
what you're capable of getting I'm
guessing if you got [__] tons of money
though you might be able to get the
older stuff and you sit there and you
live stream and then people are live
bidding on packs before they open wow
who wants this one and then people will
bid for it and then you'll live open it
and then you'll just and the rare card's
always like the second to the last one
or whatever so you're always there's a
way that streamers are revealing these
things so he's doing that once people
bid on those and like this is the one
that you've opened and you showed and
stuff like that then you'll actually
seal the back up and mail it out to that
person you should do that on JK maybe
it'll save the channel honestly it's
it's a fun thing let's do it bro to be
honest I did all my isn't here into
Pokemon unless there are Logan and you
buy a bunch of fake Pokemon cards oh no
try to sell the box and the guy's like
even validate that this is a real box
and it goes oh actually this is fake and
lost like what wow millions of dollars
is that what really happened yeah yeah
didn't he or some YouTuber spend like 10
mil or some [__] on an nft and it went
to like two books oh that happened a lot
of people didn't it yeah like
the dragon eggs are still a pretty
they're still pretty cool no I traded it
for a match now because it has six pack
so Martinez got involved in whatnot a
retail Entertainment app where you can
buy and sell a bunch of unique items he
said we ended up doing a box break on
whatnot and we turned 50 000 worth of
Pokemon cards into a hundred eight
thousand in the first show wow speaking
on his new business adventure the former
NFL player added I'd say I work at least
60 to 80 hours a week on this business
whether that's looking for new cars on
eBay to buy and resell or reaching out
to people on Instagram or friends to
find new Consignments that sounds 18
hours a week like if you're about that
life like imagine if you're a gamer and
you already spend that much time anyway
playing games and you're getting paid
for it but not only pay what you're
paying you're paying [__] good she
said uh he revealed he sold a card at
Golden auction for a stirring 672
thousand dollars wait this is one card
one card must have been a macho it was
for sure that must have been a six-pack
of my child dude I still have that
[__] card and that just you know for
context that was over half of Martina's
base salary with the Las Vegas Raiders
which stood at 1.035 million and he says
overall he earns about the same as
during NFL days but he doesn't have CTE
no more yeah that was it he he said he
revealed another reason why I quit
football and said the long-term effects
of playing a high contact sport were
definitely a factor in his decision
those guys are all what a smart sensible
person especially if you got something
else that like you're [__] passionate
about how cool and you actually like oh
[__]
you'd rather be with the NFL football
playing a [__] Pokemon these days
though hey you got the money it don't
matter he gets some cosplay girls now I
know these days they got so many uh 60
70 hours anime and like Pokemon groupies
and like
because that's their generation they got
some babies this generation nerd is in
guys they're just I was just born in the
wrong generation jocks are no longer the
leading was it choice right it's toxic
masculinity man right correct dude
that's why I think it's cool as someone
that was eligible for something like the
NFL is also a power player in Pokemon
it's crazy that the NFL distracted him
from his passion yeah yeah yeah that's
how good he was he's so good the NFL
[__] distracted him he's like a Bo
Jackson type but yeah with nerdy [__]
can you guys make a career shift like
that like would you be able to just go
and do something for 60 80 hours when
you already established yourself doing
something else
is there something that you you don't do
as your job that you could do for 60 80
hours that's what I'm trying to find is
like what do I really like like for
example
um like also if you've already if you've
already built like a a following and
there's already some sort of like hype
and then you also have money already to
like get into things like that I think
that there's options right you know what
I mean but if you're like starting over
from scratch that's different so like
this I don't like doing anything for 80
hours no that's all I need variety dude
yeah me too I need to do a lot well you
wouldn't be necessarily doing like that
one craft you might be doing like things
around that industry in that field
trading because I probably spent that
much when I was opening up joombie
because I had to but I mean it's not
collecting Pokemons that's probably way
fun variety driven people to do that if
you have too many interests I don't know
I'm trying to think how you would even
be able to do that I could see for
example let's say
um
like stopping everything else and just
doing for like uh irl's Twitch streaming
or something you know what I mean
because then like the IRL category is
really just anything that you would
normally want to do anyway it's just if
you're already a social media
personality then people are just down to
follow whatever it is you do whether you
go into gaming whether you're unboxing
[__] whether you're just [__] uh
reacting to some [__] whether you know
what I'm saying you still have to have
some sort of foundation platform to like
have that be uh encompassing your life
for 60 to 80 hours that's what I'm
saying like based off of what he said
it's kind of like would you be able to
like Drop like what you're already at
and it's like in this circle it's kind
of people are already on social media
and doing stuff like that it's like take
away like take away like barbell Brigade
and like JK and he's still doing like
yeah all of his like regular like
surfing camera stuff but then now you
can just like stream it and then maybe
make a make a living off of that
hypothetically I really like swimming
and like any water [__] like [__]
Scuba diving whatever
but I think like you can't do that 80
hours a week 80 a week underwater for 80
hours a week that's what I'm saying is
like how passionate are you to doing one
thing live streaming is different though
right like live streaming live streaming
is like a that's a different game
especially when you're like unboxing I
feel like that's like gambling you know
sometimes with gambling you could just
be there you don't [__] have to eat
because there's this like adrenaline oh
yeah yeah like am I gonna get something
and you're making money like when you're
if you're on the clock and you're just
constantly seeing money rolling I bet
you you can sit there for a long time
you know what I'm saying for like 50
weeks though you know I might go to
commit two three weeks what if you're
making like [__] 20 grand a day like
maybe you don't you'll get desensitized
after a year I might need to take a
break or something I think it's it's
also that weird thing where like money
doesn't necessarily like you'll you're
just mine's gonna adjust yeah I think
once 20K will just become the norm then
it's no longer wow 20K yeah because I
think think he's genuinely he loves that
he loves Pokemon and then I'm I'm like I
don't know if I'm obsessed with anything
to that level to where I can do it that
long because it doesn't sound like it's
about them what if what if somebody's
paying you like 10 to 20 000 per day and
you just have to like screen porno
that's that's too much bro but that's
yup that's I'm not that passionate about
it yeah but you're not like angry at it
either the thing with this guy is right
it's not just that he has a thing he
loves but he has an edge on it yeah he
does that's the main thing there's
there's an edge like if you don't have
an edge it's different it's not fun
there's something he knows that a lot of
people might not and he's doing that
edge yeah because I don't think I'm oh
okay slash he's got access right right
like if you have fifty thousand dollars
to start on your first one day yeah
that's your seed yeah you're you're in a
different realm of like profits you know
because he's already been making that
while he's an NFL like getting that
salary yeah like selling a car for like
six hundred thousand dollars a step down
from his other salary like that's okay
you know what I mean that's a different
totally different experience I would say
like I don't know many people that have
that kind of a passion towards something
that they can just switch whatever
careers but there's also the
conversation of like what you are in
that industry like he might just be in
the entire NFL just like another
linebacker who's maybe like XYZ string
or like only has so much on his contract
whereas like you jump into like the
Pokemon world
so then that means his cards are worth
more than his card
[Music]